the Centers for Disease Control is
warning people to stop using
e-cigarettes the reason the number of
possible cases of vaping related lung
illnesses has more than doubled in a
month right now there are more than 450
possible cases in 33 states health
officials say at least five deaths are
likely linked to vaping dr. Jon LaPook
joins us now with more John good morning
good morning Dana the CDC says the
reason people should consider not using
e-cigarettes is that the investigation
is ongoing
and though the agency believes a
chemical is involved there's no
definitive cause for the lung illnesses
the CDC reported a third death in
Indiana in addition to two others in
Illinois and Oregon still under
investigation are two more deaths in
Minnesota and California PAMP Antonis is
with the indiana health department
vaping is the only common factor in
these injuries to date many individuals
have reported vaping THC the ingredient
in marijuana or other substances but we
do not know what else may have been in
these products a study released showed
both THC and nicotine were involved it
described 53 cases of vaping related
lung disease since April in Illinois and
Wisconsin most were healthy males with a
median age of 19 37 percent of patients
reported vaping only THC the chemical in
marijuana that produces a high 17
percent reported only using nicotine
products and 44 percent reported using
both 18 year-old piper Johnson was on
her way to college when she wound up in
a Colorado intensive care unit had I
waited 36 hours longer I probably would
have died or been put on a ventilator
the CBC did not identify any particular
brand of e-cigarette but expressed
particular concern with vaping products
purchased on the street or tampered with
by users the American vaping Association
says the CDC is creating anti vaping
hysteria and that adult smokers should
not be scared off from using
store-bought products to quit smoking I
think anytime you see something this
serious there you
stand why there's so much concern
there's still so much we don't know
though right now yeah it's true and
remember there are two different things
here one is that people right now are
getting these lung illnesses and it
seems like it's something in the last
six months or so so it's something new
there's been vaping going on for a long
time but is it something that's in the
street product that that's possible we
really don't know but remember that the
e-cigarette device is like a chemistry
set you're putting all the stuff in and
you're brewing it up and who knows what
are you creating so often we see these
diseases developing the smoking related
disease is developing much later after a
long time of use the median age here is
19 what's going on yeah and what that
does is it shows that this is a young
person's problem right and that's the
whole thing the you know you can say
well okay we're using baby because we're
stopping people who are smoking
cigarettes from smoking them and that's
a good goal but if that was the
marketing goal it was a huge failure of
that marketing goal because it turns out
that the huge explosion has been in
young people so if it does turn out that
it's nothing that's in the normal
store-bought UV cigarette devices it's
something that's being added and found
on the street that's one thing it
doesn't negate the fact that these young
people should not even be using these
vaping devices in the first place
a lot to think about dr. Jon LaPook
thank you for being here